ah jetzt so kleidchen weiter volk
bereits wohnungen zum glück habe ich
hier eine mütze liegen die in einigen
tagen online geht
[Musik]
aber so richtig gut wird es mir erst
gehen wenn ich jetzt noch einen leckeren
tee trinken würde aus einer mega schönen
tasse aufkommt die etwa auch bei den
spaß beiseite meine lieben freunde heute
soll es natürlich nicht um einen
merchandise gehen was in einigen tagen
im lukas ablaufen wird sondern um einen
kanal was auch nicht ganz richtig ist
uns war es heute ein bisschen ernster
meine lieben freunde
das habt ihr denkt ich schon am titel
erkennen können am sammler kennen können
und das erkennt man auch jetzt gerade
hier eine generelle stimmung im moment
aber auch dafür eignet sich die neue
münze perfekten kann sich einfach über
die nase ziehen
da kriegt man einfach nichts mehr
schaffen um allerdings aufs thema
zurückzukommen meine lieben freunde
heute werden wir mal bei einigen kanälen
vorbeischauen die immer unter jedem
video tausende kommentare schreiben von
wegen harmoniert main kanal und bei
3.240 70 ipad dafür befinden uns hier
auf meinem youtube kanal und wir gehen
einfach mal auf mein neuestes
hochgeladenes video ich habe dort
natürlich selbstverständlich ein daumen
hoch gegeben solltet ihr bei diesem
video jetzt auch mal bitte direkt tun
ist sollte hier meine kommentare
eigentlich schon relativ krasse aus zum
beispiel wenn ich jetzt hier
draufklicken haben einige auf diesem
markt pro geantwortet kannst du aufhören
zu spanien habe ich schon blockiert weil
er halt irgendwie was geschrieben hat
von wegen
[Musik]
noch müssen die banken nämlich abstoßen
dann hab ich mir heute einfach mal
gedacht er luca die blockiert diese
ganzen spammer immer nur und löscht die
ganzen kommentare aber was wenn die
wirklich richtig guten content machen
klar dann ist es immer noch nicht okay
meiner ansicht nach richtig viel unter
videos zur spam und werbung zu machen
aber wenn ich auf sein profil gegangen
und wir klicken jetzt einfach mal auf
die videos von mark pro und schauen ja
das ist dann nicht so guter content ich
weiß man hat mich nicht so gut gehört
sorry leute gerne abonnieren licon
klocke aktivieren schaffen wir 50 likes
acht kommen da krieg ich habe sogar
gerade noch ein kommentar von mark pro
gefunden den ich anscheinend noch nicht
entfernt habe alle die das lesen ich
wünsche dir noch einen schönen tag abend
und glück psg hier wird sie den 3200
abonnenten
zudem wieder nicht falsch ich finde es
mega lieb dass man anderen leuten
einfach sagt hey ich wünsche den
wunderschönen tag aber im gleichen
atemzug anzusagen und abonnieren ich
bitte das ist einfach nur ein komplex
die ich bei so vielen usern von dir
gesehen habe wir gehen jetzt allerdings
mal weiter unter einige andere
kommentare und ok hier ist wieder mal
wieder entfernen wie verblödet man nach
ja dieser markt pro jeden kommentar
kommentiert oder was hier auch d aversa
keine hobbys in mark pro die zeit die er
in spammen stecken würde
in seinem video stecken würde dann wird
man ihm am nächsten wieder blau gehören
eine stunde später
aha wir haben neue personen rein 09 dann
alle die das lesen ich hoffe du deine
familie bleiben beziehungsweise werden
gesund so denkt man erst mal hey
verliebt von diesen reihen
es gibt noch mehr anzeigen perez kriege
ich hilfe zu 4000 acom wir geben auf 309
eines organs total dumm was ich hier
gerade mache ich gebe den leuten nur
aufmerksamkeit das ist genau das was die
wollen 309 jeden zweiten tag ein video
und im hintergrund irgendein stadion in
seiner kanal info steht
okay da wissen wir direkt bescheid haben
wir uns allerdings mal ein video von 309
video heute direkt hier nicht mal auf
wie das kommt meinen zuschauern wird auf
drei videos reagieren und hieraus auf
drei videos von verschiedenen zuschauen
und ja das war geil wenn er mal auf
video von mir reagieren würde
rhein ich liebe deine videos bitte
reagiert mal auf 1 von mir so so waren
für wird auch ein video von mir
reagieren würde ich bin dir gerade im
schnitt vom video meine lieben freunde
hier sind sobald wolter hat 2009 1
kommentar gesehen und sogar ein video
für mich hochgeladen ich habe ihn gerade
so ganz einfach gewesen
ich sehe ich dass luca ich komme ich auf
eine nebenklage
oh mein gott leute leute ich komme muss
ist
mein mann 3099 aber bei dir hast du dir
verdient der erste tisch ist ja nie eins
der turm und die qualität vom video hey
den sieg ich glaub ich hab ja alle die
jetzt schlecht den englischen heidekreis
halt so was wie von den verstecken von
[Musik]
beide geist verstecken und fangen
sprachen lernen da allerdings begeben
wir uns weiter auf die suche nach werbe
kommentaren um diese leute aus zu
checken
hier schreibt jemand f500 abos ohne
video kannst du deinen freunden sagen
sie sollen mir zu den 1130 helfen dann
helfe ich dir auch nicht sogar moniert
entstand abonniert dort zurück bevor
aber lieber yoshino omg morgen kommt der
bräutigam intro auf seinem kanal gibt
letztlich
[Musik]
er filmt jetzt hier
dr aha effekte da ist aber ein bisschen
da ich gestrichen
da würde ich sogar einen merchandise
kaufmann etwas raus bringen würde
allerdings weiter nach komischen werbe
kommentaren und klicken deswegen einfach
mal hier auf 25 kommentare anzeigen wir
sehen schon hier ein kommentar von
nahwärme namens
das war sein name also spaß also spaß
achtung hilfe ich werde extrem krass
gemobbt und oft verkloppt ich mache
trotz meiner sprech angst und meine
sprache das dazu videos bitte schaut es
euch an eine mitschülerin hat mich fast
er wirklich wurde im mcdonald's
restaurant verprügelt über das
wochenende in der schule eingesperrt und
in die mülltonne geworfen das hört sich
extrem krank an und ich will dieser
person noch nicht unterstellen dass es
gelogen ist nur damit die person abos
bekommt allerdings schauen wir uns den
kanal von der person jetzt einfach mal
an und was wir hier direkt sehen sind
relativ viele videos zu dem thema also
vor drei tagen von der woche vor zwei
vor 24 343 wenn wir uns beispielsweise
mal dieses video angucken es ist dunkel
hier und es geht darum dass er im
computerraum eingesperrt wurde wenn wir
uns die beschreibung angucken steht dort
darin musste ich schlafen in klammern
unbequeme dann ist er ein amazon link
und das ist auch kein normaler amazon
link sondern ganz unten von der
beschreibung steht wenn ihr etwas kauft
bekomme ich eine provision um eine
krankheit behandeln zu lassen
der preis bleibt für euch auf amazon
derselbe der erste bürostuhl der
angezeigt wird wenn man bei amazon
bürostuhl eingibt und wenn ich jetzt auf
diesen link draufgelegt habe was ich
gerade getan habe bekommt dieser user
innerhalb der nächsten 24 stunden nicht
da irgendwas auf amazon bestellen
beispielsweise morgen mir irgendwie
neues ladekabel oder so bekommt eine
provision davon
es klingt leicht komisch und leicht
erlogen seine ganze geschichte
allerdings schauen wir uns mal sein
video an
[Musik]
so geht es nahezu die ganze zeit und das
nicht irgendwie bei einer minute oder
zwei minuten sondern über 10 minuten 7
hier sehe dass hier das video wiederholt
sich
die am ende sei dann kurz 14 minuten und
dann hört es auf denn über zehn minuten
kannst du bekanntlich
werbung schalten
also mehr geld damit verdiene ich will
dieser person aber wärmer hier wegen
nichts unterstellen wenn das alles ist
okay sehr cool dass du darüber videos
machen wir das thema mobbing und darüber
informiert aber die beschreibung voll
mit das fängt an bei mir langsam zu
stinken klammern ekelhaft dann ist sein
amazon link oder sind einfach socken
verlinkt oder damit hat mich ein mädchen
fast erwürgt und dann ist hier das
verlinkt ein schal eine krankheit dafür
auszunutzen dass du darüber geld
verdienst der gab es schon verloren
meint jung oder was und jetzt kommen wir
zum nervigste und youtube kommentaren
überhaupt und zwar sind es solche krass
müsst youtube 1 tm 2020 googeln zum
gülle gleichzeitig gefunden und das sind
dann wirklich einfach irgendwelche bots
die das so oft hier untereinander
hinschreiben du kannst einfach nicht
blockieren die halt immer neuen code ich
habe mittlerweile schon das wort googeln
auf eine blacklist gesetzt damit diese
kommentare nicht mehr kommen wenn jetzt
allerdings andere leute ein video
schreibt wenn wir jetzt andere leute
unter meine videos 1 kommentar mit
google schreiben wollen damit der
kommentar von denen auch automatisch
ausgeblendet wenn wir dann mal
beispielsweise auf solche kanäle
draufgehen sie mir einfach so was nicht
jeder du kriegst als einziger daumen
runter so familie die kommentare sind
sogar deaktiviert ich frage mich warum
die youtube kommentare so geworden sind
wie sie geworden sind und warum youtube
da auch einfach nichts gegen unternimmt
an der stelle mich dass heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ich will überhaupt keine
negativen vibes predators weihnachtszeit
wir sollten alle glücklich frohen munter
sein
allerdings ist es mir gerade den letzten
tagen extrem krass aufgefallen wie das
wieder mit diesem ganzen codes und
werbung und lügen in den kommentaren nur
um abos abschnitt absoluter es hat sich
leider vermehrt in den letzten tagen und
ich möchte einfach euch sagen den leuten
die sich denken hey so gute idee sich
gegen lüge einfallen zu lassen dass in
hunderttausende videos rhein zu stemmen
um damit abos abzuklappern hey bitte
verpisst euch es ist nicht böse gemeint
so ihr können ganz nette menschen seien
aber warum machte das ist bringt doch
nicht eure art ganz viel lieber hier
draußen die leute die sich bei
kommentaren mühe geben egal ob es
positives oder negatives feedback ist ob
es kritik ist oder ob es irgendwie ein
lob ist oder irgendwie so ich nehme
alles gerne an außer dumme werbung und
dumme beleidigungen die dann irgendwie
gegen die mütter gehen oder keine ahnung
was ich hoffe wir können einen change
machen in la kommentar section auf
youtube bitte meldet kommentare die
extrem viel werbung machen die lügen
schreiben die fake news verbreiten die
irgendwelche +18 links dar 1000 oder
irgendwelche youtube codes mit denen man
auf google geld verdienen und glück
bekommt nicht nur bei mir in den
kommentaren sondern auch bei allen
anderen youtube damit würdet ihr uns
allen den riesigen gefallen tun und wenn
youtube da schon nichts gegen unternimmt
dann können wenigstens wir das machen
lupus trust
[Musik]